two to nothing a three minutes in at three two
goal leads two nothing 3-1 42 and lost 54 eel
up ice with petrangelo eel shot score Jack eel
short side on the golden KN first shot Vegas
with the lead right off the bat eel coming up
pandro driving and eel what a shot short side
upstairs great release by eel his 14th and the
Golden Heights grab the early one nothing lead
as he rips that pass corpos solo yeah this is
STP three of a five game Road Trip starting
with a loss in St Louis Drew banister first
game behind the blues bench and then the loss
in Dallas on Friday where they had those three
two goal leads to the Vegas line taken away by
Zack whitecloud cter gave it right back to kubal
into the offensive zone his shot fought off by
Hill had to go up the heel of a stick that's
a good setup from kachuk now Norris down the
wall a couple of steps out to Sanderson and
around the stla Norris a chance scores that
broke through Hill and Josh Norris with goals
now in three of his last four has tied the
game as it moves around and it's going to go
from Hill right to left see how he moves on
that play not much movement as Norris able to
put it between the pads and that will end aen
Hills return now there's just you can tell that's
not a normal position Chen playing it off to giru
now rot scar rley Greg Let It Go his second
of the Season both Ottawa goals on the power
play and it's two to one well Greg able to go
upstairs and thre a screen good job it starts
you win the draw Puck possession this a quick
little play CH does a good job to keep it and
a nice little back pass as schmigle parked right
in front there's the pass through right to Greg
and you can see Logan Thompson can't see that
and that's a good shot upstairs has been touched
up for two here in the opening period That's s
Right Barber the St touch pass to W eel trying
to break in a save made by Corpus solo Jack eel
in alone with a great chance to tie it hopefully
it doesn't repeat itself this year I know it
worked out fine last year but you don't want
to test that bouncing Pucket Center I to Maro with
some speed rot score from distance Jonathan Maro
on the glove side on Corpus solo and we're tied
at two upstairs an air ma pass good job little
chip ahead and watch John Marshall I'm not sure
that c Zoom stick can change direction but it's
still from way out and that just fools corpos
solo pass the glove hand as marallo briefly
was tied with eel for the lead back to loose for
Brett Howen Howen bumped down Norris keeps it in
Norris looking again cuts in front Thompson
with a poke check and then made the save on
the followup off the Stick of jaru Thompson a
great job as he's going to poke check here and
then it's the followup a huge Hutton pass
and errant one and easy clear back down by
Norris but in the lead pass W
has a step W and alone backand
score Nick W on the power play to
give the golden knights the lead
as he finds a scam to send W in all alone
and Nick W loves to go to that back hand
on a breakway where's the little kick right there
the kick to the backand as he beats Corpus solo as
he has his fifth of the season and the goldenite
power play comes through to give them the 3-2 lead
only giving up four shots here to the Senators
Drake bson out of temp stews left Fe it out High
Anderson to kachuk centering pass tip and a
save Thompson on bson Thompson delivers here
great little play by kachuck to the inside the
Thompson's moving does a good job to squeeze the
pads as BS trying to chip this to the five hole
catch the pads open he kind of catches the stick
and that left PAD as Logan Thompson able to hang
on holding back to Sanderson and around the Norris
passes in es skates and stone takes it away away
Stone and Stevenson will break short-handed Stone
into the zone to Stevenson scores what a pass by
Stone so Chandler Stevenson with a shorthanded
goal and a 42 lead this pass the patience the
touch little drift and then the Finish are you
serious clerk what a goal as the golden I grab the
4-2 lead Chandler Stevenson short-handed goal into
the Zone pass picked off by Bon Martinez gets it
right back Maro open shot and a save coras solo
as Martinez carries in the zone finds Marshall so
Prime shooting area right at the top right back
Stone comes as golden eyes clear the Zone barev
Carlson a chance that's blocked by hammeck and
that hurt him and then hag misset another chance
score a shooting gallery for Vegas and Ivan barers
shf buries it and the golden knights have opened
up a 52 lead late in the second just continue to
pressure here's the play out of the Zone watch the
center two guys are going to go for a change that
leaves an odd Man play will they take advantage
shot wide Carlson that one's blocked by HCK and
then he shot wide it's barers off the back
wall and clear frustration by the Senators
so this is a team that is extremely fragile and
frustrated right now as barbashev able to put it
in Carlson plays it to Maro petrangelo to eel now
petrangelo Mel walking in to in the Middle Stone
rebound score William Carlson after Stone had
the original chance Carlson with his 14th it's
6-2 around he thinks shot watch how he draws
everybody there there's that movement Stone
right to that s there in the saw and a great
job by Carlson staying persistent on that off
to the side one chance initial save and before
Sanderson can clear and William Carlson able
to put it in you can tell there was something
wrong with Aiden Hill wasn't able to go down
didn't really move on the shot went off his pad
and in his night was done Go's wrist shot that's
off the crossbar and out of play the game so
early but taking charge as it's gone on here
yeah and they've done a good job getting backed
in and finds Maro cuts into the corner pass into
the slot picked off and kachuk on the move with
stla broken up by Martinez dusel flings it down
low backand that hit the post Kook have
that bit back in and it was an offensive
zone turnover that led back to this chance and
off the outside of the post similar to Buffalo
coming in here the other night Buffalo's doubled
that drought they miss playoff 12 years in a row
but right now the Senators heading in
the wrong direction kachuk scores in
tight puts it off the posted end for his
14th they get a 63 game with a minute 21
left Stevenson throws this to the middle of
the ice looking for McNab you like the idea
for that poo play but that's that situ game
situ situations where you need to understand
where you are a turnover and a quick little
passing play nice play Norris BS zoo with a
long wrist shot Off the Mark carier on the
wing protecting the puck and the beat goes
on for the golden knights against Ottawa they
it nine straight wins and 10 of 11 all time